so let's say that we have a round table
and we have three chairs around that
round table so this is one chair right
over here this is another chair and that
is another chair and we could number the
chairs that is chair one that is chair
two and that is chair three now let's
assume that there are three people who
want to sit in these three chairs so
there is person a there is person B and
there is person C and what we want to do
is we want to count the number of ways
that these three people could sit in
these three chairs what do I mean by
that well if a sits in chair one B sits
in chair three and C sits in chair two
that is one scenario right over there so
this is a one one of the possible
scenarios a and C one C and C 2 B and C
three another scenario could be B and C
1 B and C one maybe C still sits in seat
two C still sits there and now a would
be in C 3 so this is one scenario and
two scenarios so my question to you is
how many scenarios are there like this
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think through it so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it now let's
work through it together and I want to
do it very systematically so that we
don't forget any of the scenarios and
the way I'm going to do it is I'm going
to create three blanks that represent
each of the chairs so here it's in a
circle but we could just say okay that
blank is chair one that's the blank for
chair two and that is the blank for
chair three and I'm going to start with
seat one and I'm saying well what are
the different scenarios okay could sit
there be could sit there C could sit
there and then for each of those figure
out who could sit in seat two and then
for each of those figure out who could
sit in seat three so let's do that so
first who what are the scenarios of who
could sit in seat one so actually maybe
I'll write it this way so maybe I'll do
seat seat one so right now we're only
going to fill we're only going to fill
seat one well a could sit in seat one in
which case we don't know or we haven't
filled it C 2 or seat three yet so this
two or three B could sit in seat one and
we haven't figured out who sits in C 2
or seat three yet or and then we could
have C sitting in seat one and we still
have to figure out who's going to fit
sit in seat two and seat three now for
each of these let's figure out who could
be sitting in seat two
so seats seats one and two so for this
one right over here either we could
either have so we have a and seat one
for sure
now we could either have be sitting in C
2 in which case in which case actually
I'll leave this blank although you could
use a little bit of deductive reasoning
to figure out who's going to be sitting
in seat three so I'll leave seat three
blank or you could have C sitting in
seat two and now we still haven't
figured out who's sitting in seat three
although once again a little bit of
deductive reasoning might tell us so
these are the scenarios where a is in
seat one now what about when B is in
seat one well we could put a and C 2 and
we still need to figure out who's in
seat three or we could put C and C 2 and
we still need to figure out who's going
to be in seat three and then finally
let's look at C where C is in seat one
well you could either put you could
either put a and C two or you could put
B in seat two all right now let's fill
out all three of the seats so seats
seats 1 2 & 3
well for this scenario right over here
there's only one option that you could
put in C 3 the only person who hasn't
sat down yet is person C so this will be
a B C and what would this would be well
the only person who hasn't sat down in
this scenario yet to fill this chair the
only option for this chair there's only
one option here it's going to be person
B so it's a C B this one is going to be
b a c c is the only person who could sit
there a is the only person who could sit
there B C a and then here B is the only
person who could sit in seat three and
here a is the only person who could sit
in C 3 so how many scenarios do we have
we have 1 2 3
four five and six and six is our answer
that's the number of with scenarios that
you could have the different people
sitting in the different chairs now I
know what you're thinking okay Sal you
know this was a scenario with three
people and three chairs and you know I
might have been able to just do this
even if I didn't do it systematically
but you know what what if things get a
lot more company and if I have many many
more chairs what if I had 60 chairs well
that the numbers the Senate number of
scenarios would get fairly large what if
I had what if I had five people and five
chairs even this method right over here
would would take up a lot of paper space
or a lot of screen space what do we do
in that scenario and the realization
here is just it's just thinking about
what happened here we said look how many
people how many people could sit in seat
in seat one so when we were filling if
you're going seat by see how many how
many possibilities were there to put in
seat one well if you're seating in order
if you haven't filled seat if you
haven't filled any of the seats yet if
you haven't filled any of the seats yet
right at the beginning well there's
three possible people who could sit in
seat one you see it right over here one
two three because there's three possible
people now how many people for each of
those how many people could sit in seat
two well for each of them let's say the
scenario where a is sitting in seat one
there was two possibilities for who
could sit in seat two notice let me do
this in a different color so this right
over here for each of these for each of
these for each of these three there's
two possibilities of who could sit in
situ - if a is sitting in seat one you
could have either B or C and C - if B is
sitting in seat one you have either a or
C for C - so for each of these three you
have two possibilities of who could sit
in situ and so for each of these for
each of these so you have six
possibilities where you're filling in
three times two when you're filling in
how many the the scenarios four seats
one and two and then for each of those
how many scenarios are who could sit in
seat who could seat in the last seat in
c3 well for each of those there was only
one there was only one possibility for
who could
it for who could sit in seat for who
could sit in seat three we see it right
there and that's because there's only
one person left who hasn't sat down yet
so how many total possibilities are
there well 3 times 2 times 1 is equal to
6 and so if we were to do that same
exact thought exercise would say 5 seats
let's go through that exercise it's
interesting so if we have 1 2 3 4 5 so
this is 5 seats with 5 people sitting
down and we want to figure out how many
scenarios are there for all the
different people in all the different
seats well for the 4 the first seat
there's 5 different people who could sit
in it now for each of those scenarios
there's for people who haven't sat down
left yet who could sit in the second
seat now for each of those scenarios
there's going to be 3 people who haven't
sat down yet so those are the people who
could sit in the third seat if we're
filling out the seats in this order now
for each of all of these scenarios
there's two people left who haven't sat
down yet who could sit in the fourth
seat and then for all of these scenarios
well there's only one person left who
hasn't sat down who would have to sit in
the fifth seat so if you had this exact
same thing but instead of three chairs
you had five chairs the number of
scenarios would be 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 which is what 20 times 6
which is equal to 120 scenarios and so
you see that the scenarios grow fairly
quickly and if you're wondering hey this
is kind of a neat mathematical thing 3
times 2 times 1 or 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 like if you start with a
number and you multiply that number
times the number one less of the times
number 1 less than that all the way down
to getting to 1 it seems like a neat
kind of fun mathematical operation and
lucky for you or maybe unlucky for you
because this might have been your chance
at Fame this apparition has already been
defined it's called the factorial it's
called the factorial operation so this
thing right over here this is the same
thing as 3 factorial you write this
little exclamation mark this right over
here this is the same thing as 5
factorial so if in general if I said
well if I said let's say 6 factorial
that would be equal to 6 times 5 times
four times three times two times one
anyway hopefully you enjoyed that